From literature to plays and movies throughout the world,
Humanity's fascination with love is just as strong as our obsession with heartbreak.
But, is a broken heart simply an abstract concept, or are there real physical affects on the body and the brain?
Whenever you endure physical pain, such as a cut or injury, the anterior cingulate cortex is stimulated.
Surprisingly, it's the same region of the brain that's activated when you feel excluded or experience the loss of a social relationship.
Perhaps physical pain and emotional pain aren't as different as we once thought.
Think about the ways in which we describe lost love.
"He ripped my heart out", "it was a slap in the face", "I'm emotionally scarred."
This use of physical description
paints a clear relationship, at least in language, between emotional and physical pain.
In fact, studies have shown that human beings would rather
be physically hurt than feel social exclusion.
But why would these two different experiences
elicit the same feeling in our bodies?
It's clear that our bodies use physical pain to prevent
the risk of imminent danger.
But, from an evolutionary perspective,
anything that increases our overall survival and fitness as a species
is likely to persist.
The rise of relationships and social bonds between lovers and friends alike
became an important part of survival for many species.
You look out for me, and I'll look out for you.
And just like your desire to not be burned by hot coffee again,
animals desire not to be socially alone.
The pain from both instances increases our chance of survival
by avoiding less desirable outcomes.
You're more likely to survive and reproduce
if you're not alone.
This can be see in studies of primates
who, when separated from loved ones,
experienced an increase in the hormone cortisol
and a decrease in the hormone norepinephrine,
causing a major stress response.
Ultimately, this contributes to the depression, anxiety, and loud crying documented.
For humans, a break up, loss of a loved one, or isolation
can trigger a similar reaction,
creating the perception of physical pain.
So, how can we alleviate this pain?
After all, band-aids or creams are meant for physical wounds.
Studies have shown that high levels of social support
are related to low levels of pain,
whereas socially alienated individuals show poor adjustment.
So if you're feeling brokenhearted,
surround yourself with friends and family,
as difficult as it may seem.
And if someone you know is suffering emotionally,
be there for social support.
Because, scientifically, us humans -  we all just want to fit in somewhere.
This episode of AsapScience is supported by Audible.com,
the leading provider
of audiobooks with over 150,000 downloadable titles
across all types of literature.
If you'd like to learn more about the brain,
I recommend the book "Thinking, Fast and Slow" by Daniel Kahneman.
You can download this audiobook
or another of your choice for free at audible.com/asap.
Special thanks to audible
for making these videos possible
and for offering you a free audiobook at audible.com/asap.